in 1860 the country was on the verge of
the Civil War and the city of New York
was hunting for one of the most infamous
criminals of all time though it's
someone you've probably never heard of
his name was Albert Hicks and he's been
called the last pirate of New York a
bridge between Blackbeard and Al Capone
when the worst of the worst transition
from raiding ships to joining mobs his
chilling story is detailed in a new book
by rich Cohen well when I first heard
about Albert Hicks and his crime I
learned about this ghost ship and I just
could not get that image out of my head
for years and years and years rich Cohen
has been trying to write a book about
Albert Hicks for more than two decades
and what he calls the craziest summer in
the history of New York this is the home
of the river pirates who would come out
of the sewers of the city on row boats
at night and hit the ships in the harbor
steal and kill and then disappear back
into the sewers now armed with new
research Cohen tells the tale in the
last pirate of New York this is right
before the Civil War the thing that was
notable one thing that was known about
Hicks that drew me to him was everybody
who was an operator downtown in the
slums which are the five points was a
member of a gang and these were the
crazy gangs almost out of the movie the
Warriors you know the dead rabbits the
Chicka stirs the forty thieves the River
Rats Albert Hicks was not in a gang
because people were in gangs because
they protected them there was protection
Albert Hicks wasn't in a gang because he
didn't need to be protected by anybody
people need to be protected from him
police believed Albert Hicks killed more
than a hundred people as he traveled the
world from New York to California Hawaii
Mexico and Tahiti he would join a ship
kill the crew and plunder but then he
returned to New York one last time in
1860 he murdered the crew of an oyster
sloop threw the bodies overboard and
tried to sink the ship but it did not go
down so a haunting empty ghost ship was
found the next day and one of the most
sensational murder hunts in American
history was on detectives follow the
trail to Providence Rhode Island that's
where Hicks was found with a
hundred and twenty-one dollars and the
murdered captain's belongings he gave a
very famous colorful unbelievable
confession it's one of the strangest
documents in American history Hicks said
there were five people on the boat with
him when he committed his final crimes
the three people he killed himself and
the devil who he said possessed him and
urged him to kill the jury took seven
minutes to convict him the sentence
public execution at Bedloe's Island now
Liberty Island they wanted him to be on
high ground and they wanted him to be
able to see the water the city the
Narrows which is where the
verrazano-narrows bridge is tens of
thousands of giddy New Yorkers watched
from the harbor and the island so is
he's as he's looking out here he's
seeing thousands of people yet in the
harbor on boats yeah everywhere else
it's like a carpet of ships you can
always walk from ship to ship to ship
the ship all the way back to the city he
came onto the island surrounded by
thousands of huge howling crowd he falls
to his knees said a prayer got up and
said make haste hang me quick those were
his last words
so what was the site of the last public
execution in the city is now Liberty
Island right Statue of Liberty if you
wanted to write a book about America and
you were a novelist and you you know
thought everything wasn't always perfect
that was something you'd make up but it
happens to be true which is the fact
that right underneath at the feet of the
Statue of Liberty stood the gallows
where the last pirate was hanged it's
medieval it's medieval it was like
something out of one of those old
paintings you could come down here and
travel on this ship that Hicks was being
brought to his death and for $1 you
could travel on the same ship as them
drink all the beer you could drink all
the oysters you can eat watch the
execution this is not a story you read
about when you go to Liberty Island no
maybe it should be the government was
trying to send a warning but the
barbarism of the public execution
appalled even the most jaded tabloids it
became the last time New York City
executed someone this way what can folks
learn from the story of Albert heck
today they learn about what came before
the New York that they know they learn
about what America was like when it was
still wild and lawless and they learn
how that those elements that made that
city go are still all around us this is
still the same New York and that's what
fascinated me it was just like a picture
earlier in the stage of development it's
already all they're not sure there's a
better nonfiction writer in America than
rich Cohen he brings it every time and
this is the same history isn't always
good no is but in this case but think
about that when you go to Liberty Island
next time truth is better than fiction
yeah what about you go